[Musique]
on nous a prévenus que quelque chose se
prépare et si jamais il ya une fin à
cette guerre interminable
ce sera grâce à toi et à ta puissante
main droite
juif à côté désolé c'est mon erreur
nous sommes la dernière ligne de défense
nous combattons les forces des ténèbres
c'est quoi ce tu t'attendais à une
enseigne disant quartier général secret
[Musique]
salut tu as une pièce d'identité les
trésors sérieux tubes à transformer en
arme voulait seulement qu aider à
devenir le meilleur
toi
[Applaudissements]
et
dire qu'il ya des pères qui donne des
lego à leurs enfants savaient pas sauver
le monde ou chez pas quoi
ça fait quelque chose de spécial ouais
ces malades pour démolir des trucs
et le meilleur est unique espoir de
l'humanité
penser qu'on devait combattre les
monstres pas travailler avec eux
à
têtu trèbes de monstres tu dis regardez
dans le miroir
c'est un truc excusez moi
mais ce que je dérange
contraire tu arrive juste à temps